situation in afghanistan is obviously
deeply
concerning and risks instability not
just in the region but globally and
undermines the legacy of british
soldiers of coalition troops
and of brave afghanis over the last 20
years
um and you know whilst the decision to
withdraw was not britain's decision
alone of course
we do have an obligation here i think to
step up and lead and support the afghan
government just this morning the afghan
government has asked for international
support
an invitation to the international
community
we must respond to that and respond
urgently we can't turn our back on
afghanistan and the people of
afghanistan and so what i want to see is
our government stepping up
and leading on this and calling for an
urgent meeting of nato and an urgent
united nations security council meeting
what we can't do is walk away we can't
turn our back this invitation has now
come in for support
let's step up and lead on the
international stage set up that nato
meeting set up the united nations
security council urgently should the uk
be offering more support in terms of
sending more troops perhaps doing more
in terms of humanitarian work not just
evacuating british personnel over there
at the moment well there's obviously the
evacuation
exercise going on and i hope that is
carried out as quickly as swiftly and
safely
as possible i think in terms of what
comes next
this request has come in from the afghan
government this morning
for assistance
let's set up an urgent nato meeting
an urgent un security council meeting
and decide what the appropriate action
is but it can't be
to walk away and to turn our backs
who's to blame for what's going on in
afghanistan right now well i think that
uh the decision to withdraw
is not the right decision and the timing
is certainly not right and there appears
to have been a miscalculation of the
strength of the taliban on one on the
one side and the resilience of the
afghan troops and government
on the other um i think over the 20
years there's been a failure to build
the political settlement we needed but
now
the urgent question is what do we do in
response to this response this request
this morning for international um
assistance and international response
britain needs to lead on that the prime
minister should lead on this he talks
about global britain this is um a test
of that
let's convene the nato meeting urgently
and the united nations security council
urgently um and in that context discuss
what the appropriate next action is but
this is urgent so the u.s president joe
biden is wrong to withdraw all u.s
troops from afghanistan i think the
timing of the nobody wants troops in
afghanistan indefinitely of course they
don't u.s or british troops
but the timing of this i think is in
question um and
the i think miscalculation of the
strength of the taliban and the
resilience
of the afghan forces is something that
we've got to addre just say
well decisions being made we walk away
now
let's convene urgently lead on the
international stage
and put in an appropriate response to
the to the request that's come this
morning um when you look at what's gone
on in afghanistan over the past week um
and we're hearing that the us believes
that kabul is going to fall to the
taliban the next 30 days it's hard not
to come to the conclusion that the
20-year mission there led by the us and
with nato forces has been a complete
failure well look um
over 20 years
we should be very proud of what uh the
coalition forces have done and what
british soldiers have done in
afghanistan
a number of them are paid
with with their lives and their families
obviously carry that with them um so
they have made a material and a very
important difference
what we can't do now is let that all
unravel to
undermine the legacy of that 20 years by
simply turning our backs walking away
let's respond a significant development
this morning this request for
international assistance that's respond
appropriately
lead on the global stage
on this and convene those meetings just
finally on afghanistan you've called for
lots of international meetings should
mps be recalled to parliament at this
stage well whether we're recalled
parliament's a matter for the government
um i think the pressing matter for the
government at the moment is have you got
a response to this morning's um request
for assistance have you got a plan and a
strategy that's the more pressing issue
than at the moment where the parliament
should be recalled that's a matter
for obviously the government
and and
i think to many in afghanistan it looks
like the west is abandoning the country
do you see it that way we have
obligations to afghanistan we made
promises to afghanistan and we cannot
walk away unless let this turn into a
humanitarian crisis and probably a
refugee crisis as well
because you know there's a real risk now
that international terrorism will take
hold again in afghanistan so we can't
walk away we can't
undermine the legacy of the last 20
years there are families across the
country who've lost
loved ones in afghanistan
and
we should be proud of what they did but
not now just walk away and turn our
backs okay i'm turning to the situation
in plymouth yeah do gun laws need to be
strengthened in the uk well it's a very
good thing that there's an already
investigation into
how the perpetrator caught a gun license
given back to him
very recently i think there are wider
questions how on earth did he get a gun
license in the first place what
background checks were done so i'm glad
there's the
investigation already into why the
license was returned i do think there's
wider questions here and that could uh
involve a review of the gun licensing
laws because there are other questions
here that urgently need to be addressed
i mean the people will look at this and
say you know a young man here living in
a uh a town centre
how on earth did someone who was
suffering from mental health problems uh
get his firearms license renewed
why did he have a good in the first
place well i think there are exactly the
questions why did he have a gun license
in first place what were the background
checks that were put in place there's
now a lot of stuff coming about out
about the perpetrator a lot of that will
have been in existence beforehand so
a good thing that the particular issue
of the return of the license is already
being investigated but i think there are
wider questions here about the gun
licensing laws that are going to have to
be looked at how on earth did this come
about in the first place